book "Untouchable: How powerful
people get away with it"
rocketing up the charts right
now.
What report do we have about
what's going on?
>> There are three
investigations swirling around
Donald Trump.
We have been here before, the
swirling phase.
Number of them have resulted in
indictment.
Let's take stock starting with
that justice department
investigation.
It has -- it was 73 days ago, I
counted, when Merrick Garland
appointed jack Smith as special
counsel.
Jack Smith has two jobs, to
investigate January 6th first of
all.
We have not seen movement on
that.
Could be happening behind closed
doors and to investigate the
mar-a-lago documents scandal.
As you said, we have reporting
that two people have gone into
the grand jury that recovered
those documents.
That tells us that jack Smith
continues to move ahead in that
part of the investigation.
Now how is this going to play
for now?
When jack Smith is ready, he
will make a recommendation to
the attorney general, indict or
don't indict.
The final word, however, is up
to Merrick Garland.
By law, he has to give jack
Smith's recommendations, quote,
great weight.
So we'll see how this plays out.
Ultimately this will be up to
Merrick Garland.
>> Of course, Bonnie Willis in
Georgia is looking into former
president trump's alleged
efforts to overturn the election
in that state.
How could that affect the 2024
presidential campaign?
>> This could be the most
immediate case of all the
pending cases.
The district attorney we found
out in the last couple of weeks
has finished her presentation to
the special grand jury.
We're not seeing that report as
of this moment.
The special grand jury cannot
indict, but what the special
grand jury can do is make a
recommendation.
Ultimately, again, it will be up
to Bonnie Willis whether she
wants to go to a regular jury,
to seek an indictment, and fan
Willis said to a judge, that,
quote, decisions are iminnocent.
Now people asked me mean, is
that a legal technical word?
No.
It means imminent.
It means soon.
Whatever fani Willis thinks is
soon, is soon, but I would take
her at her word and I think we
will hear what her decisions
are.
>> How about that hush money
payment to stormy Daniels?
Is that back again?
>> This is the oldest and the
newest.
This dates back to 2016, but
there are brand-new developments
here.
We've just learned that the new
York D.A., the Manhattan D.A., a
state-level prosecutor here in
Manhattan is going to put
evidence of these hush money
payments in front of a grand
jury.
That could result in an
indictment, and it's interesting
because this goes back so far in
time, and I think the question
is what has happened?
This goes back 6 1/2 years to
before the campaign.